my thing is I'm not even that famous man
there's so much better people to hate on
do you even see it online do you ever
catch yourself like looking or I think
it's unavoidable it's also not people's
fault like the way social media YouTube
works like the algorithm works it
encourages hate you're going get more
likes and more feedback when you hate
can you sue people I don't have you
tried doing any of that the internet's
always going to internet there's nothing
you can do to combat that if you're
going to critique stand up my fight
picks or my football picks all good
that's what the internet's for now if
you're going to go out there and
defamation like Bren his kids or beats
his wife then you got my attention I'm
going to come after you high breath yeah
that's the thing with this show I've
been doing it seven years and now it's
like okay maybe it should make money
type you know 100% flew out to LA to
record You' be dope if you did this as a
living which you should you're good at
it and you get good guest so there's no
reason why this shouldn't be your you
know focal point and then also as a
comic it's just a good way to you know
it's just all the same ecosystem yeah
what what would you say for like what
kind of advice would you have for this
show if I could selfishly for yours ask
you yeah it's it's primarily right now
super engaged in like the comedian
Community comedy fans aren't that aware
of it yet and like so the numbers
reflect that so I'm but at I'm at a
point you know I flew out here to do
podcast is like where's the ROI how can
we start making money back you I mean
how's how's the social media clips and
stuff like that how's the real it you
know yeah that's where I need to be
consistent you I mean get those out
there it's going to help cuz you you can
only do so much in what you're what
you're doing but it helps and I I've
never understood this
when Comics whether on a show or they're
on your podcast when they don't blast
out your stuff like it's it should be
like we're a team we all help each other
out so like after you do a clip of this
I should blast it out and then people
are like my fans are like oh what's this
and then look oh that's dope that was a
different interview or whatever that a
fun interview and they go down the
rabbit hole and then it just builds
builds builds whoever you have on it's
there's nothing worse than like hey man
you mind posting this you know it's like
but I always like whatever we do food
truck or whether it's fighting the kid
whoever we have on I'll let them know
hey uh we're live and I send the clip up
to them what they want to do with it I
won't be like hey make sure you post
this but you know I come from the place
like yeah man this is part of the gig
like you come on the show like part of
this is you know you scratch my bag I
scratch yours it's also just the right
thing to do it's like comics when I
first came to LA and I started standup
they would send me the Flyers I'm like
oh cool and I'd always put it up always
I blast it either on the main page or on
Twitter especially on my story and so
many clubs like oh thank you so much for
posting the the graphic that you're on
the show I'm like yeah why would who's
not doing that like nobody like oh
interesting why would you want to
promote you're on a show like ah Comics
like to save that stuff just for their
tours or whatever like who cares I don't
get it why is everyone so weird about
this stuff this show is all about Comics
helping Comics you know it's interviewed
over 400 comedians on here all about
comedy so that is that's the spirit
behind what we're doing so maybe I do
need to tap into that a little bit more
and that that intention of one to
interview someone and like celebrate
their success and learn from it same
thing when marketing it is like hey
let's all help each other do better and
spread like the you're a good dude and
obviously you've been doing comedy for a
hot second in Atlanta so it's like
uh yeah what like you doing well doesn't
take away from insert you know Bill Burr
or insert me it has nothing to do with
it who yeah there's enough pie for
everybody I don't get it yeah like the
the more the bigger your platform is
well it's a home for Comics like there's
only a few podcasts that Comics can go I
mean don't get wrong there's a lot of
podcasts but if you become this hub for
Comics great it's another Outlet where
we don't have to bow down to this
[__] you know major media you know
conglomerate and jump into their where
they dictate what you can say what you
can't and they fizer as a freaking you
know sponsor it's like that's what you
guys want to promote all right cool but
or you could get really big and then
Comics have a home to go to yeah that's
what I'm starting to picture it as and
we were talking before the show is we
were like talking about your studio is
I'm starting to picture it almost as
like how Carson would like showcase
comedian and their talents and put them
in a good light and let them be funny
and find new fans I'm starting to feel
this show was heading that direction of
me just interviewing Comics but also
setting them up to succeed and thinking
of maybe putting a studio in Atlanta
that is more like late night Vibe for
lack of a better term be but really like
just go all in on that vision of like
kind of Johnny Carson Vibe yeah that'd
be dope like when like when you had
earthquake on recently how was that
interview just s like do you guys know
each other we reviewed his comedy
special on our YouTube channel his his
recent one the legendary one yeah dude
and it was like 14p per minute and he
really enjoyed like how he went into the
science of the special he's such a good
comic dude I mean he's been doing over
30 years his nickname's earthquake yeah
it's not because of his weight when he
walks in it's because when he performs
that literally people think there's an
earthquake it's it's one of the best
specials I've ever seen like still it is
is undeniable and he he's one of those
vets who recognizes like oh younger
Comics like appreciating the craft of
Comedy so we like connected and then we
actually met in it Atlanta I was
supposed to interview him in Atlanta and
this was when I was just oneman banned
my own camera and everything and I had
an audio mou function on my recorder
like it would not read the SD card
nothing worse so then we're just in his
dressing room and I'm like all right
well we're do it on my phone and he's
like well let's let's do it the right
way he's like we're friends now we'll do
it the right way so then a few months
later we just connected and I've been
going back and forth with his publicist
and then we booked a date for me to be
on his radio show and to also record
that's dop the podcast in his Studios so
it was just just networking and just I
think years of Goodwill that a veteran's
like oh I see this next Generation let
me let me help them out yep no and
that's what and that's how it should be
man yeah that's really how it should be
yeah I don't like the the negative
competitive which I think I think I feel
like Joe Rogan really like shifted the
mindset in comedy of like we're not
against each other we're really together
and we can like Rising tide can lift all
boats he seemed to be like the tip of
the spear on that Y and then he took
that ship you know he went to Austin so
that's the same philosophy out there in
Austin but you know now LA's like Game
of Thrones because the king's out you
know got his head cut off by head cut
off I mean he moved to Austin and then
now now it's back to survival the
fittest which is fine I you know I can
do both I can adapt with both I'm down
but um it was a better time when Rogan
was in town how was it
different uh it's just you know when you
got a A guy at that magnitude going this
how we do it everyone respects everybody
we support each each other in every way
possible whether it's podcast putting
each other on shows like this is how we
do it like people are like I guess that
even if they didn't want it like that's
what I got to do if that's what the guy
says and that's how he carries himself
we're going to do the same so it was
just a more welcoming time then he
leaves and that kind of standard's gone
and you know I I think you know you
still got the Big Boy you know you got
uh Santino and Bobby doing you know bad
friends you got brt kryer he just does
his on his own s girl's gone Theo's gone
Tim Dylan's in and out right um so it's
just it's just kind of everyone spread
so that kind of you know those kind of
uh unspoken rules are gone oh which is
you know I'm down for the lawlessness of
town I'm down for that I'll survive in
that but it's just it's just not as fun
if that makes sense yeah have you been
on his uh Mothership yet I have not I
have not I've uh I'm there Saturday but
when I come in I'm there for the fight
companion and and you know the cards out
there start at 9: so we get done you
know sometimes a 3 4 Hour show so we
we'll get done at 1: 2: in the morning
and I don't want to go up the you know
the comedy the mothership when it's you
know 2: in the morning so we need to
figure out the time where I'm not there
doing shows It's just tough with my
schedule too like I don't get me wrong
I'd love to go there love to perform and
we'll figure something out but it's also
when Joe asks me I'll be there you know
but but it's it's it's tough with my
schedule tough with schedule it's tough
and he also doesn't book it you know
Adam eot who used to work at the store
books it and Adam's my boy so we just
got to figure something out you know
that that makes sense but uh it it's
with kids and it's just I don't live the
life of some of these Comics you know in
their 30s or damn near 40s that don't
have kids or don't have a wife where man
if I was younger if it was you know
before my son came oh I'd be on a plane
out there on a Tuesday night and you
know having drinks off Sixth Street and
doing my thing but now it's it takes a
lot for me to leave I don't care what it
is man I don't care what it is like me
and Bert when I was on his show had this
conversation you know Bert started
crying you know cuz Bert's the best in
the world man he's the absolute best guy
in the world but you know he he tour is
different he gets a tour bus he's gone
for you know weeks months at a time and
he did that even when his kids were
young and so I was asking him about his
movie and this is before it came out and
he's like hopefully with the you know
the Russia War who knows man kind of
screws me over that's terrible man
that's like your big break not that you
need it everybody knows who are but when
you make a movie about your your the
machine store this a big deal he's like
I know and I'm like how long were you
out there he's like man I was in uh
wherever they shot in Rush he's like I
don't like four five months I'm like God
it's insane he's like let me ask you
this I know you're a homebody and you
had kids if they asked you to do a movie
but you couldn't see your kids for four
you know six months would you do it I'm
like no no I wouldn't do it he's like
you're telling me if they're like he you
can be Batman but you can't have your
kids six months like that's the
difference between us dude it's just not
I've just gotten this level it's not a
success level maybe it's a maturity
level now nothing's worth missing the
time you leave for a week and if you
have a two or three-year-old they're
completely different man you're missing
that stuff it's just not that's where
I'm at man yeah and is that the
motivation behind thick boy Studios is
like oh let me just build something
right down the road that I can kind of
like your friends with Rob Deer deck
that's basically what he's done like his
office is right down the road too is
that like your mindset now yeah I think
so just everything's more convenient cuz
I used when I was with showtime for six
years we're in Santa Monica but I still
lived out here in the valley so I drive
you know depend on traffic at least an
hour hour and a half every day there and
back talking about two three hours so I
was I wasn't able to pick my kids up
from school drop them off so it was just
you know one thing about running your
own stuff there's a lot of other things
that I didn't anticipate happening when
you when you're you know when you're the
captain of the ship cuz when I was at
Showtime I was the talent I just showed
up did my thing they took care of the
staff the booking the cameras the I no
no overhead I was like whatever and they
just pay me my salary and I got out that
was an easier simple life man it was a
lot easier and there's pros and cons
because you know they're not coming out
of here you know they're not going to
move their operation out to Calabasas
but um it's good and bad the good is I
can drop my kids off of school every day
pick them up uh I don't miss baseball
games the bad is you have to be a boss
that's not what I sign up up for you
know even as an entrepreneur like I
don't have to fire people talk to people
about their salaries like I just want to
show up and be silly with my friends and
you know have a good time with these
pods but so heavy lights the crown with
that stuff man it's good and bad but
life was much much more simple it was
even more simple I was fighting the UFC
my life was less stressful as a UFC
fighter than it is now as a comic comic
comic CU UFC you have one goal whatever
let's say your fight December 15th or
16th okay I have this Camp I I know what
to do in a camp show up it's very black
and white was it a success win or lose
great but with comed it's like you know
you can be doing this for the next 40
years man and so you got to you got to
pace yourself where when to work how to
work how long how long you want to be
out it's just a different animal man
yeah but even in the MMA like you were
selling supplements door too and a
friend was paying for your training
correct so it's like so that wasn't like
a cakewalk either you know it wasn't a
cakewalk but also didn't you know it's
just you you're you're lifestyle changes
you know back then all I had to worry
about was myself so it's like I don't
care if the money comes through or
someone screws me out of payment I don't
care well I have employees who are my
friends who I care about so they got to
get paid I got kids they you know they
got tuition you know I got a wife I got
a mortgage multiple mortgages like you
know cars yeah yeah cars yeah who's
going to pay for these skinny jeans dud
and my shoe collection so it's just back
then it was like I didn't care dude you
know it's much more simpler you have six
shows here is it six shows here uh what
do we got fing the kid golden hour shop
show food truck cbat fight companion and
then am I missing anything we'll do the
one-on ones yeah round six so it feels
like you maybe have figured out like a
framework or some sort of workflow to a
successful show oh I don't know uh maybe
maybe from an Outsiders perspective but
the caveat to that and me and Theo used
to discuss this is it better to
do less and So you you're working less
so you have more free time to do what I
don't know what Theo doesn't during the
day I have no clue what he does during
the day Hees one show a week I don't
know my thing is is I'm a uh I'm
addicted to work I'm a workaholic and I
have to it's a balance I've met with
experts how to deal with that but I'm
like a shark if I if I stop moving I'll
die so it's a problem so you'll see I've
built all these shows I've done all this
stuff and I I constantly want to work
and do standup every night and multiple
sets and multiple shows but there has to
be a balance is it better to do less and
get all the views on just that or spread
it across six different shows and do a
million different things you know so I
don't know if I figur out the formula
you know I don't know if I have you know
I I think as I get older like less is
more Theo and Theo told me that a long
time ago but and that that that's what
works for him CU for Theo he's like I
just don't like having to you know do
you know prepare for shows you know
because after especially shop show or
the fight shows I have to you know
research do stuff like that and then on
King the sing was me and him like that
was a a roast battle me I mean I was
writing roast me and him were going back
and forth so you that show wasn't
something that you wanted to do twice a
week you know and he was like man I
don't like having the anxiety or the
pressure of constantly working Monday
through Thursday like I want my freedom
like yeah that works for you and he's
figured out man he's crushing it he's
one of the funniest people I know and
that that works for him but then Rogan
who work Monday through Friday do you
know three four hour pods and just roll
with it and then stand up at night so
that's what worked for him Adam Cora do
I think Adam has 10 podcasts he does a
week legit like 10 different shows on
top of the Cora show like he's working
he has like a car show Dr Drew show the
Adam Corolla show he does all the stuff
and stand up at night oh jeez everyone's
different yeah but like with how
mandal you know Howe he owns JFL he's on
Amer gots town
he's you know he's he was on all those
game shows before that the guy you know
he's probably worth I don't know
guessing here 3 400 million he asked me
to go to his podcast Studio it's not far
from here I walk in I'm looking it's
dope I'm looking around he's asked me to
look at his fish tank because I know
fish tanks I'm like yeah yeah all the
fish are dead but whatever and uh he uh
he's asking me like you know just
question about the podcast game stuff
like that I just looked at him I was
like why what do you mean I'm like why
do a podcast you're on
NBC on America Got Talent why are you
doing a podcast he's like cuz you know
though that's a season so I shoot those
Seasons I'm done and I'm my stand up but
he's like with uh podcast I control the
the workflow he's like and I have to
work he's like I'm addicted to working
he's like not even about the money I'm
set he's like all I I just it gives me
something to focus on like that makes
sense yeah teach their own but I would
yeah I would not be that guy yeah at a
certain point I think I've heard you say
that you you your business isn't run by
like what going to make money like you
said you don't make decisions based on
like what's going to make the most money
never never so now that's different when
I have employees CU then sometimes I
have to do certain things where I would
never agree to because I know it's going
to bring in this certain amount of money
I'm like all right it's more work for me
but everyone's going to eat all good I'm
done for that but yeah I never go oh
let's do this cuz I know it's going to
be the cool trendy thing to and to make
a ton of money no that's not the
business I'm in ever what is the so what
is like the structure of like like like
a podcast like monetizing a podcast
because it seems like you're you're very
Savvy at like okay advertising but then
you also seem to have merch figured out
and then also like patreon like what are
what are the streams that you build to
like elevate a show yeah it's so it's
all on the ecos system right because you
have your your podcast or your podcast
network uh which people will tune in to
you know every week every day hopefully
if you're doing it right but then and
then that promotes the comedy so it's
like it they go hand in hand because the
better your podcast doing the more
tickets you're selling so th that's in
that ecosystem and then with me I think
during Co I realized it even before then
but you know when it comes to podcast
reads there's so much more you can do
with that because the podcast read is
just an audio read and they might get
some return but you know even I fast
forward through the ads so it's like
this can't be a good when I when someone
talks me like well here's 20 grand for a
read you know for for this month I'm
like you're not going to see your money
man I'm telling done you're not going to
get you're not going to sell $20,000 in
underwear like you know you might be
good for brand Association but you're
not get that money so my deals now I I
have those obviously we have the podcast
reads but now it's more of a 360 deal
where it includes social media whether
it's the fighting the kids social media
gold hour social media my social media
my independent endorsements will trickle
into the show so it's this whole
ecosystem where it's just not predicated
on uh certain amount of views you're
getting stuff like that so they're
getting the biggest bang for their buck
and so it's not predicated also you know
cuz summer is a slow time for podcast
you know or predicated on we have this
huge guest let's make sure we do this so
it's it's just a way to kind of ride the
ways where it's not this these ups and
downs you know that so that's and then
with the patreon patreon was interesting
because some guys kill like Tim Dylan
kills it schultzy kills it right there's
certain guys who just crush on patreon
I'm not never been a big fan of the the
the pay structure behind a pay wall and
uh I think Theo's thing and again Theo
doesn't get enough credit as far as
business wise
because um I gota be careful I say just
because of the stuff uh with contracts
but with king and the Sting the the show
was blowing up blowing up blowing up and
we thought we deserve this much and we
we were expecting this much and that
didn't come to fruition so Theo's like
why are we let
this certain Company sell things when
we're not getting the money why don't we
we have the fan base why don't we go
behind the the payall behind the patreon
he's like they'll they'll rally maybe
not everybody but they'll rally so so we
did that so we decided to cut half and
half again that's not because we wanted
to make all this money it was because it
was a way to secure our future in the
show going let's not Bank on them coming
through and paying us this we can put in
the time it's a great show and the fans
support us and was like I don't know $5
he's like you know it's a cup of coffee
at Starbucks hopefully if people
subscribe to that then we don't have to
just we're not slaves to the system that
was the thinging behind that we still do
the patreon now with gold hour it's just
that you know people get familiar with
it so you don't want to change but the
pay wall is tough because there's so
much free content out there but the
super fans they're they're down for the
ride like those are your ride or dies
whether it's a good show B those your
ride or dies you know I don't know I'm
just I'm seeking your guidance here as
like you've seem to have fix figured out
like the media side of this podcasting
game and now I'm looking to elevate this
podcast really into a show y so I'm
really looking to like getting and I
think that's something you have to do
because I think you know we've been
doing fireing kid for 12 years when we
started in brion's garage you at almost
13 years now so when we started everyone
in their gay a didn't have a podcast
like you know there's no uh level entry
there's no barrier so anybody can do it
people see the success of shows whatever
show you're into and they go I can talk
I can do that so they do it doesn't mean
it's be successful so now it's it's
oversaturated and and especially in the
past year the podcast Bubble Burst the
Spotify Deals they lost their ass not on
Rogan they saved their ass on Rogan
they're lucky they signed Joseph Rogan
and I don't Brogan and I will argue
about this I don't give a [__] he got
underpaid he you you you look at the the
valuation of their stock and how much of
that company's worth now because they
signed Rogan compared to what they paid
them you know I'm a shark when it comes
to business they underpaid my man he
they underpaid he should got paid a lot
more all good all good that's his thing
you know I still I would done I'm just
saying you look how much that company is
evaluated now and then you look at the
money they tossed the the obam that uh
woke soboy um what's his name [__] uh
Prince Harry and mean marle you look at
all these shows shows that in the other
shows I'm fan so I won't say them
they've all lost their ass on that
except for Joseph Rogan they could have
taken that money and just put it towards
him you know and signed a long deal
because his Deal's up soon oh I didn't
realize that yeah I think it was a
three-year deal good luck with that
three year 100 million
yeah but but even that he he was making
people like oh my God so much money he
was making you know I don't give away
his finan I mean he was making good
amount of money but it's not like that's
far off from what he's doing on his own
yeah yeah yeah so I guess there is
there's a if I going to get the middle
class of podcasting I'm fine with it
yeah hell yeah real class good living
how important is mindset to what you do
because it seems like everything you've
done whether it's excelling football at
a high level MMA at a high level stand
up in two years you're shooting a
Showtime special like
podcasting dude but the fact that you
were willing to even think that as a
possibility you know I think as
comedians we can be battered and be like
well I'll do my 10 years and then when I
pay my dues type deal but you were like
no I'm like doing this now type deal and
I think that's rare in comedy especially
so like is there a mindset to you being
able to excel in an industry so fast or
like what do you attribute to that uh I
I I don't know I wish I could because I
don't are you aware of it though that
like you're you enter industry justware
yeah I'm yes and no and Sam tripley
helped me out with that um because I was
being hard on myself over some something
he goes dude do you know how hard is
become a headlining comic he's like
because you're in LA and because who
your friends are and you're surrounded
by headliners think that's the norm he's
like go to Florida go to Philly go to
New York even go to go to freaking
Atlanta go you go go down to you know
Tennessee he's like dude it's so hard to
be a headliner and there's great Comics
he's like so for you to be able to
headline in that short amount of time is
is nutso man it's the fastest I've ever
seen he's like it's nuts but you got to
remember from my perspective I'm it and
it's a bling and a curse because I have
blinders on and so I see you know sagur
ker Rogan um you know Joey
diazen Theo all my all my boys these
headlines I'm like oh this is what you
get ComEd this what you do and then now
as I get older um been you know
headlined for what six years now been in
comy about eight so it's like as I get
older I'm like oh that's yeah and I see
these now I I don't bring a crew with me
I have the the clubs or the theaters
book the local talent because I want to
see you know I want to see what's going
on there and there's some great comics
mhm and so I'm like oh that makes sense
yeah now now I get it but uh you living
you learn I learn the hardest way the
advice I would
have for Comics like learn from me man
as far as there's no rush there's no
you're going to see these Comics posting
Clips on social media and that's the
trendy thing to do and you see everyone
doing everyone's posting crowd work
because they want to ruin their whatever
their 15 minutes or 30 minutes or their
special material you see all this crowd
work and I don't I don't have the answer
do something different everyone's doing
that do something different and also
don't be in a rush to get that stuff out
like Let Let It build like for me and I
had advice from Rogan from Brian like
don't do a special yet wait uh with with
uh my other special with the green girl
poppy everyone's like oh got two million
views yeah I I would have waited on all
of it I would have waited till I get 10
10 years and there's a reason they say
that so it's like don't be in a rush I
know to be tempting cuz you want to get
it out out there you see all your
friends doing or Comics you look up to
doing don't be in a rush do the do do
just wait man just wait just wait
there's no advantage to doing it early
there's absolutely zero Advantage so why
didn't you
wait uh I didn't wait that's a good
question um it's tough and you know put
yourself in my shoes your two years in
the comedy Showtime comes you offers you
this amount of money more money than I
ever made in the UFC more I was making
that podcast and offs you do this hour
that you've been doing you know for two
years you're like yeah why not why not
you know and I was like oh this would be
cool people realize I've only been for
two years fast comic ever get a major
Network special they're going to
celebrate this no that's that's not how
this works that what no they're not
normal human beings nobody no that's not
how it works they're going to despise
you for it they're going to hate you for
it I didn't I didn't see that coming all
good I have big shoulders for a reason I
was built for this hate it doesn't
affect me but I don't like it you know
and I you know I wish I could change
some things but it is what it is but I
have thick skin so um yeah I just I
didn't see that coming I was like oh
really you guys oh okay but and then but
then I put myself in the shoes like dude
that guy over there's was doing it for
15 years then got a network special like
yeah man he's not going to like that of
course yeah I get it I get it and I have
no I have no ill will towards any of
those people I get it yeah you seem to
you seem to be good at like just
focusing on what you can control and not
letting the negativity get to you I mean
I have to otherwise you know I'd drive
my you know my TRX off a freaking
Highway you know off the PCH my TRX it's
it's it's it's a Dodge truck it's not
much of a flex I didn't say like
Lamborghini or nothing it's still a
truck I'm a blue collar guy here
yeah you know yeah so yeah but what else
you can do stop quit no that's not me
that's not never going to happen but
have you done anything to try to like um
like suppress this or like get on top of
it like it's just what do you there's
nothing you can do I mean can can you
sue people I don't have you tried doing
any of that no I mean we got we we have
a lawsuit with a guy who made like 3,000
videos again if you're going to critique
standup or my fight picks or whatever my
football picks all good that's what the
internet's for now if you're going to go
out there and uh defamation like you
know whatever brenon hits his kids or
beats his wife then you got my attention
I'm going come after you yeah that that
game I don't play and the guy's
suffering from that so that is whatever
you know the internet's always going to
internet there's nothing you can do to
combat that but you know I'm in the
business of likeability so when I go on
the road I'm I think too for younger
Comics or people getting into this you
think that the internet's all the
comments or whatever it is is real it's
not real man I make a business off
likeability I have I don't know 10
endorsement deals that's that's how I
pay my bills I have 10 endorsement deals
uh and this isn't a flex it's just
showing you that right you know I'm more
loved than I am liked you know I go to
coffee shop I can't I can't I was just
with my brother I can't go anywhere
without meeting nice people man you know
who love what I do and then also I sell
tickets on the road that's how else I
pay my mortgage you know so that that
stuff is real that's attainable I see
and meet those people so I think that's
what helps me navigate through all the
darkness so you don't even do you even
see it online do you ever catch yourself
like looking or I think it's unavoidable
especially now I run all my stuff again
so it's like you know I you won't see me
like going through YouTube comments or
going through Instagram comments you
know I'll post and ghost but then I'll
go on my friends walls and stuff and say
what's up you know or or like their
stuff so so I see what's going on but
for the most part I post in ghost
because whether it's good or bad it's
not you know the good ones IO that's
cool the bad ones it's it could ruin
your day yeah dude cuz even like even
like for this show like when when I've
been recording on my own like I'll have
to make sure the recorder is going and
look at the camera to make sure the
camera's going in the middle of the
interview and people will roast me in
the comments like stop looking at the
camera Michael Sarah they'll say stuff
like that so even like those little
comments I'm just like oh I'm just
trying to do something here I'm trying
man but but now sometimes there might be
some sort of benefit from it if they're
like hey man but it's just about their
delivery if they're like hey it's
distracting when you do this on the Pod
like okay that makes sense I can I can
work on that I can stop doing that but
like for the longest I had a problem
interrupting it just my nature I
interrupt people like man you interrupt
too much good good all right good note
but when it's that and that's why they
just don't know the delivery you
know okay cool well I appreciate you
talking about that because it's
something as as a comedian myself and
seeing your career and how quickly
everything's happen and just seeing the
backlash of everything I'm just like
looking at as a comedian like I mean
they it seemed like this is a guy who's
just like built his own thing and built
his own trying to do my thing yeah I
don't get it so that's that's what even
in researching you for this interview
I'm like looking at stuff and I'm just
like I don't I don't know the context
for this they need a villain but when
you look at especially in com like you
know Matt r at all for sure yeah a great
kid I've known him since teenager yeah
exactly me too so just such a good
person and you look at the hate he's
getting he'll address some of it you
know he'll talk about it but people hate
success you know and and I'm even
remotely close to what Matt's doing I
mean not even remotely but you look at
Drake Drake releases an album it's also
it's also not people's fault like
there's a lot of you know the people are
going through stuff and maybe one of
their Outlets is to focus on whoever my
thing is I'm not even that famous man
there's so much better people to hate on
they're going to give you content I mean
I guess cuz I do so many shows so like
man at least we know Monday through
Wednesday this guy's going to release
videos we can hate on man there's
there's way better podcasters or Comics
out there to hate on that are going to
give you good material but I'm not the
guy you know so uh but there's literally
nothing it is what it is you know but
you you see it you know with Matt R I'll
hear you know Comics while I'm the Green
Room make comments about it I'm like
yeah yeah you know he made like $15
million in two days selling out his tour
it for two years like you think he gives
a flying [__] you guys should be
celebrating this yeah you guys should be
like holy [__] that's attainable oh wow
and he's only been do how long you know
it's like man take inspiration from that
and the the reason your mindset of
bringing because it's easier to destroy
than to create that's why they do it
it's it's it's a sheet mentality to
destroy them to create creating is
[__] tough even if you do it and it
doesn't go over well all good at least
you're taking a swing those people that
are doing this stuff bringing down matt
r or Drake or me or whoever they're not
taking any
swings think about that they're not
doing anything yeah they're just
reacting people creative you're reacting
to my creativity okay
okay do you do you yeah so when you have
that in your mind do you create with
like more hesitation now or just never
I'm not the guy I was built for it no
never never never and I know when you
were in MMA you had like mindset coaches
things like that so like what did you
learn since I was a kid it was like this
though oh yeah yeah since I was a kid I
mean even playing football at a young
age playing football at a high level
it's just it just comes with the
territory you can't please everybody so
what do you what do you do to stay I
guess just like Teflon like is it selft
talk what do you have any like
techniques work yeah just keep working
you know keep working and the proofs in
the put in it's like if I go up the
Laugh Factory tonight if nobody laughed
if I bombed every night then I'd be like
oh man maybe these these you know these
critical people you know these critics
are right but it's just not it's just
not real it's not real but I and again
it's not their fault because the way
social media YouTube works like the
algorithm works it entices it encourages
hate you're going get more likes and
more feedback when you hate instead of
like on this podcast that was great like
thumbs up that might get one like but if
they go they make fun of you know
whatever the way you dress or you're ha
or you know two white dudes or whatever
that's going to get more of a
conversation so that's a algorithm
problem that's something that Elon Musk
and uh Mark Zuckerberg need to work on I
can't control that so I don't worry
about it I can't do nothing about it so
I get it too you know if this what's
getting you attention it's like having a
kid if he does this and he knows he gets
attention he's going to keep doing it
but if you don't give that attention
he's like all right that's not the angle
let me switch up the gears here so they
got to Swit you know once the these big
you know Instagrams Facebook and YouTube
stop kind of promoting that people going
to switch their gears but beautiful well
uh well as we land This Plane here a
question I ask every comedian on here is
their worst like bombing experience if
they ever been booed if like a crazy
Heckler just something in their career
that they just will never
forget it's a good
question and you can chew on it for a
minute nah I gotta I'm trying to think
there I all of them have been learning
lessons like um I had one at the Improv
I was on back toback shows I was on the
8:00 10 o'clock show the 8:00 show for
whatever reason and some Comics did
great I just it was the worst bomb I
ever had and I was like three years into
I'm like Oh my it was so bad you can
feel the sweat down your back like oh
this is the worst feeling in the [__]
I want to die and there's some great
comics on there so they saw the bomb and
I'm parked out front of the Improv so
I'm sitting in my car just like oh man I
was trying to think of an excuse not to
do the 10 o00 I'm like I don't want to
do this and Chrystal Leo walks by this
is like eight years ago nine years ago
and he's like what are you doing it was
like 5 minutes before the show I'm like
I'm trying to think of an excuse like
you tell them I'm sick or whatever and
I'm just sitting there my head in my
hands like this and then Chris KN goes
what the hell are you doing I'm like
dude I ate [__] that last show I don't
want to go back in there he goes no no
no you're going back this is what we do
this is what we do no no no hell no he's
like this is what we do man you threw an
interception get back out there I'm like
oh there you're right you're right and I
got back out there um I've also learned
I think before when I was first on I'd
look at the lineup and see where they
put me and i' like oh man that guy's a
killer this going to be so tough after I
do not care now I I think whoever it is
like you can ride the wave and it and
also the it restarts every comic like
you don't have to worry about that guy
you want him to crush him for if he
bombs it's you have dig out of a hole
the crowd's like oh here we go so I'm
not I'm not worried about that anymore I
think that just comes with the
experience like I I I literally I'll
just ask hey when am I well give me a
time I don't I used to ask all right
who's up before who's up after now it's
like what time you know cuz I don't
worry about that it doesn't that's a
weird mentality have like it doesn't
matter if that guy crushed you can crush
it doesn't take away there's not just a
finite number of laughs in the crowd it
doesn't matter do your thing you know so
that that show was after you would
release your special as well the oh yeah
so You' release Showtime special and
then you're at the Improv in front of
all these famous Comics yeah it's tough
one man tough one tough one dude Chris
like what the hell are you doing I was
like trying to figure out how to get out
of here yeah we all that's why I always
asked that question because every comic
at every level has bombed multiple times
you you have to yeah I have I have a few
a ton I was in uh Kentucky and I had
this bit about uh probably sucking dick
or something like that yeah I'm sure one
of the classics you know one of the old
throwback Classics and these two guys in
front of me Decked Out head to toe thick
boy gear even even it was weird for me
like take it easy out the gear decked
out in their front and they just had too
much to drink and do you know probably
doing drugs too and I could they were
having fun at first and when I got into
that dick part they're like no man I
could hear him go no man hell no enough
with this gay [__] I'm like what so I
keep going and he goes hell no and he
stand up I'm like what is happening
right now and he's like enough about
this gay talk man not around here I'm
like oh [__] so you know how I know
you're gay and dude Furious Furious but
then the crowd rallied boo they're just
drown him out and I'm like fellas you
can stay but I don't think they want you
to stay you guys want to stay and
they're no I'm like you guys got to go
man you know so yeah there's been some
weird times yeah that's but it's so much
fun no matter what it's always fun yeah
we've had a guy in uh Spokane which I'm
in Spokane September 21st to 23rd uh
this month last time we were there we
had this homeless dude break into the
Green Room with a and throw a glass
bottle and he had a sword he threw a
glass bottle it broke hit my buddy
Justin uh just on cut on Instagram hit
him in the head sliced his head open a
little bit and uh he had a sword and I
was like oh [__] cuz I always I watch
too much murder docks and all that I'm
up to date on the mass shootings like so
in my head I'm like oh tier level five
here so I'm trying to get it's before
the show so I'm try getting the guys my
brothers with me David lot we're all
running and I there's I don't know if
you ever been at Spokan there's like
three doors like it's like that it movie
we open one door open another door it's
like that I'm like uh uh uh and the
door's locked I'm like trying to do it
went locked so I'm just like [__] it so
I just freaking fullblown Bam Bam break
the door down run out but it was to the
stage so it was to the stage so I'm
like and we walk down the whole crowd
just sitting there like oh and we're
like sorry sorry I go there don't be
alarmed nobody should be alarmed but
there's a guy with a sword I don't know
if he's head this way and everyone's
like what so we walk through the crowd
it's my brother who's not small David
Lucas who's a giant uh me Justin and
where and there's like I think Chappelle
Lacy so it's like big dudes all walking
I hear one two go damn look like a
football team in this
[__] he been some wild ties man
amazing dude well um do as we end this
do do you have any closing advice for
Comics out there don't stop yeah don't
stop they you stop they win and by they
is whoever they is in your mind so uh
just and work work work man no matter
what the show if it's the trendy popular
doesn't matter just get up there man and
work you know and work that's all it is
be a Shar don't stop moving I'm
exhausted so I don't know if that's good
advice I'll probably die early but don't
stop well Brennan shop thanks for being
on hot breath than apprciate man yeah
hot breath